قاتلات الاحتلال الحربيه استهدفت منزل
يعود الى عائله النابلسيه في مخيم النصير
هذا المنزل استهدف من قبل المقاتلات
الحربيه دمرت
الطابق الثالث في هذا المبنى انتشال عدد
من الاصابات حتى
اللحظه دمار كبير في المنزل
المستهدف
منزل عئله
النابلسيه في مخيم النصيرات يعني نحن فوق
ركام هذا
المنزل الذي دمرته المقاتلات الحربيه
واندلاع
حريق في هذا
المنزل دمار كبير في هذا المنزل عداد من
المصابين تم انتشالهم من قبل فرق الانقاذ
والاسعاف التابع لجهاز الدفاع المدني حريق
في المنزل تم السيطره عليه تنزل
كان هذا مكان سقوط الصاروخ من المقاتله
الحربيه على منزل عائله البوسيه في مخيم
النصيرات حيث غارت المقاتله على هذا
المنزل دمرته بشكل
كامل يعني دمرت هذا الطابق بشكل كامل عدد
من الاصابات تم انتشاله من قبل فرق
الانقاذ وطواقم الدفاع المدني التي وصلت
الى هذا
[موسيقى]
المكان
اربعه من الشهداء وصلوا الى مستشفى العوده
في مخيم النصيرات من استهداف منزل عائله
النابلسيه هذا المنزل تم استهدافه من قبل
المقاتلات الحربيه تم انتشال اربعه من
الشهداء وصلوا الى مشفى
العوده